bonsoir enfin un certain soulagement
avant l'expiration du délai à kampala 85
passagers de l'airbus et les 13 membres
de l'équipage ont été libérés dans
l'après midi par le commando palestinien
cependant il garde encore en otage en tb
les israéliens et ceux qui possèdent une
double nationalité
en outre l'ultimatum est repoussée à
dimanche
ils ont été relâchés et sellal fait
exceptionnel à la suite de la décision
du gouvernement usera l'ia de négocier
avec les pirates de l'air avant les
délibérations le premier ministre
israélien avait en fin de matinée au sud
une délégation des familles des otages
qui exigeait que les changes soit fait
mais c'est un revirement dans l'attitude
d'israël qui n'a pratiquement jamais
céder à ce genre de chantage
tel aviv a demandé à la france de servir
d'intermédiaire dans leur libération
les otages regagneront part ils
débarqueront 24 heures après les 45
premiers qui était arrivé hier soir à
orly
il faut avoir vu l'arrivée de ces gens
jusqu'à l'heure anonyme des otages en
ouganda pour mesurer ce que signifie un
détournement d'avion la tutelle du drame
ses répercussions
le bouleversement des familles et des
proches et puis subitement découvre la
réalité des visages des pleurs des
effondrements des parents qui se
reconnaissent qui se soutiennent des
bébés l'on sert et que l'on croyait
perdus des visages rayonnants et puis
ces enfants presque gouailleur fier de
laventure qu'ils ont traversés comme un
western et des temples dont ils ont
saisi chaque péripétie avec la lucidité
de l'inconscience
ce qui est dangereux avec moi au des
grenades et des moines exclusive comment
ils ont détourné l'avion commence à
cette fois ci c'est bien un monsieur
tenais à vous a crié cabine du pilote
titulaire trois autres sont sortis
lucas et
tout le monde
fouiller l'histoire
un instant tout à ton honneur l'idée
tout s'est bien passé
déployée que tout ne rentre
et puis lors un nouveau drame d'or il ya
les familles de ceux qui n'ont pas été
libérés certaines des photos et demande
avez vous vu un tel ou une telle
comment va-t-il les libérer à qui
manifestement n'a demandé de se taire
répondent que tout va bien que ce n'est
pas trop dur et que les otages ont à
manger et à boire
il s'en suivait nuit aujourd'hui 100
autres otages ont été libérés et sont
attendus à paris dans la nuit il y aura
ce soir d'autres larmes de joie et de
nouvelles incertitudes car sur
l'aéroport d'un bébé il reste 80 otage
tous israéliens
enfermé dans cet aéroport ici même à
quelques mètres de l'airbus et il y à un
nouvel ultimatum
dimanche 14 heures cette sélection est
terrible alors israël a reculé devant le
chantage 39 prisonniers contre 80
israéliens ce soir à tel aviv
on vérifie la liste détenue dont les
terroristes demande la libération